[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
buscarlo en google cuál es el país que
tiene más mujeres en el parlamento
muchos estaréis pensando en noruega
suecia o tal vez gran bretaña pues nada
de eso la respuesta es ruanda uno de los
lugares más pobres del áfrica
subsahariana estoy seguro de que muchos
ya conocéis este país al menos los que
tengáis cierta edad en el año 1994 el
genocidio ruandés salía en los
informativos de todos los periódicos
hablamos de una de las mayores
atrocidades de la historia de la
humanidad en sólo 100 días el gobierno
ruandés masacró a casi un millón de
personas de la forma más salvaje que os
podáis imaginar para que os hagáis una
idea
eso significa que 1 de cada 5 ruandeses
fue asesinado durante décadas ruanda fue
un sinónimo de catástrofe humanitaria de
hambrunas sistemáticas y un recordatorio
de lo más oscuro de la condición humana
sin embargo hoy en día en el año 2017 23
años más tarde ruanda se está
convirtiendo en algo muy distinto
[Música]
reflexiones de ruanda invirtiendo en una
de las economías de más rápido
crecimiento del mundo tal cual como lo
oís ruanda se está poniendo de moda en
el mundo financiero un país que antes
solo aparecía en los anuncios de ayuda
humanitaria ahora empieza a salir en la
prensa económica su presidente el eterno
paul kagamé se ha convertido en la nueva
rockstar africana se pasea por
escenarios tan prestigiosos como harvard
o el instituto brookings sí vale todos
reconocen que su estilo de gobierno es
un tanto autoritario que eso de llevar
más de 17 años en el poder y decir que
gana selecciones con el 96 por ciento
del voto es de todo menos democrático
[Música]
pero quien se atreve a reprocharle algo
al hombre que está sacando ruanda de la
pobreza las cifras hablan por sí solas
desde que paul kagamé está en el
gobierno los ruandeses casi han
triplicado sus ingresos y la población
que vive en la pobreza extrema se está
reduciendo año tras año así que la
pregunta es cómo han llegado hasta aquí
y lo que es más importante realmente es
tan impresionante el éxito económico de
este país o hay alguna letra pequeña hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas y
vamos a contaros una historia que al
menos a mí me ha hecho cuestionarme
muchos de mis principios preparados
porque el vídeo de hoy va a ser cuanto
menos intenso
odio prefabricado recordad esta fecha
6 de abril de 1994 el avión en el que
volaba el presidente de ruanda fue
derribado por un cañón antiaéreo nadie
sabe a ciencia cierta quién organizó
este ataque pero el ejército ruandés
compuesto por miembros de la tribu de
los hutu culpó de este magnicidio a la
tribu rival los tutsis
los tutsis eran una minoría dentro de
ruanda que vivían en una situación de
apartheid los medios locales se referían
a ellos como cucarachas y muchos de
ellos habían escapado a campos de
refugiados en los países vecinos sin
embargo nadie podía esperar que este
magnicidio fuera a desatar semejante
carnicería
lo cual aparece a acto
el vallecano
esto varía santillana
mientras estos mensajes se difundían por
la radio el ejército ruandés estaba
repartiendo machetes y garrotes entre la
población civil
si alguno de estos hutus mostraba algún
signo de clemencia con sus vecinos
tutsis se arriesgaba a ser ejecutado por
colaboracionismo eso explica que muchos
ruandeses ejecutarán a sus mujeres
tutsis a garrotazos o que incluso
algunas iglesias católicas se
convirtieran en auténticos mataderos
humanos en tan solo 100 días casi un
millón de personas murieron a machetazos
por sus propios vecinos
[Música]
y os preguntaréis por qué los hutus
odiaban tanto a los tutsis acaso eran
tan diferentes pues lo cierto es que no
[Música]
bueno nosotros estamos locos
veréis hay muchos países africanos con
varias razas y culturas conviviendo en
sudáfrica por ejemplo hay nueve idiomas
oficiales en uganda
la cifra supera los 15 sin embargo
ruanda fue un territorio
sorprendentemente homogéneo durante
siglos una única lengua y una única
cultura tanto los hutus como los tutsis
como las demás tribus convivían en
relativa armonía hasta que en el siglo
20 y llegaron los colonizadores belgas
una de las primeras medidas que puso el
gobierno de bélgica en ruanda fue
obligar a todos los locales a
identificar claramente la tribu a la que
pertenecían de esta forma era fácil
reconocerles a simple vista
[Música]
durante los primeros años los tutsis
controlaban las instituciones del
gobierno de los belgas pero en el
momento en el que reclamaron más
independencia bélgica empezó a apoyar a
los hutus todo esto por supuesto
acompañado de toda clase de propaganda
racista
[Música]
de esta forma cuando en el año 1962
ruanda se independiza de bélgica los
hutus y los tutsis ya tenían sus
primeros enfrentamientos y por eso
muchos de estos tutsis empezaron a
emigrar a campos de refugiados en los
países vecinos países como uganda o
zaire que es lo que hoy en día es la
república democrática del congo
entre ellos este señor que veis en
pantalla que se llama paul kagamé
quedaos con este nombre porque es muy
importante
paul kagamé se crió en uno de esos
campos de refugiados concretamente en
uganda era el principio de los años 80
por aquel entonces
uganda estaba en mitad de una guerra
civil y kagamé junto con otros
refugiados ruandeses luchó contra el
gobierno ugandés y ganó así es como se
comenzó a forjar su prestigio como
estratega militar después en los años 90
kagamé líder haría varias incursiones
militares contra el gobierno ruandés de
mayoría hutu pero el momento clave llegó
en junio de 1994
y el días después de ese fatídico 6 de
abril paul kagamé entraba en kigali la
capital de ruanda con 2.500 soldados el
genocidio había terminado y ruanda tenía
un nuevo gobierno un gobierno de mayoría
tutsis donde kagamé era el
vicepresidente pero esperad un momento
porque la historia no termina aquí
imaginaos el escenario por un lado
teníamos un país completamente dividido
donde los supervivientes del genocidio
tenían que convivir todos los días con
los vecinos que habían masacrado a sus
familiares
[Música]
por el otro ruanda era uno de los diez
países más pobres del planeta y a duras
penas tenía recursos naturales que poder
exportar y como guinda del pastel este
nuevo gobierno tutsi tampoco era ningún
ejemplo de transparencia y respeto por
los derechos humanos muchos de esos
soldados que habían tomado kigali
querían venganza y durante los años
siguientes nadie hizo nada por evitar
ejecuciones sumarias y juicios con nulas
garantías públicas
por si esto fuera poco muchos de estos
nuevos ministros intentaban aprovecharse
de su cargo para llenarse los bolsillos
con el poco dinero que había disponible
mientras tanto nuestro amigo paul kagamé
contaba con el apoyo popular el carisma
y sobre todo la ambición política por
eso en el año 2000 el gobierno dimitió y
sin siquiera convocar elecciones termina
ocurriendo lo inevitable
[Música]
kagamé el presidente eterno en el año
paul kagamé se convierte en el
presidente de ruanda y llega al poder
con dos objetivos muy claros el primero
cerrar las heridas que había dejado el
genocidio el segundo sacar a su país de
la pobreza
qué hizo para conseguirlo pues viajar
tal cual como lo haga me preparo un
equipo de personas de confianza y se
marcharon a países como china tailandia
o singapur
sabéis qué es lo que tienen en común
estos tres sitios exacto son tres países
que en su día fueron muy pobres pero que
por aquel entonces ya formaban parte de
eso que llamamos los países emergentes
[Música]
kagamé se reunió con políticos
economistas y funcionarios apuntó varias
ideas en una libreta y volvió a su país
con la receta para construir un país
rico esa libreta fue la base tanto de la
constitución ruandesa como del famoso
proyecto vision ruanda 2020
básicamente kagamé se planteó que su
país debería convertirse en una economía
de renta media en sólo dos décadas un
país pacífico moderno y donde al menos
la pobreza extrema hubiera desaparecido
[Aplausos]
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
se trata del típico discurso vacío de
político en elecciones
el programa ruanda 2020 consta de 44
objetivos claros y medibles cosas como
por ejemplo que para el año 2020 1 de
cada 3 ruandeses tiene que tener
electricidad en casa tanto el gobierno
como distintas consultoras privadas se
dedican cada equis tiempo a analizar
hasta qué punto se está avanzando en
estos objetivos
[Aplausos]
y por ejemplo una de estas metas que ya
se han logrado cumplir es la de la
igualdad de género la constitución
ruandesa exige que al menos el 50 por
ciento de todos los cargos políticos
estén ocupados por mujeres y de hecho en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
en el año 2017 el parlamento de ruanda
es el que más proporción es de mujeres
tiene en el mundo entero no sólo eso la
brecha salarial entre hombres y mujeres
es más baja incluso que en países tan
progresistas como dinamarca y hay toda
una generación de mujeres empresarias
levantando el país
por otra parte ruanda ha sabido invertir
el poco dinero que recauda en un país
donde el 80 por ciento de la población
vivía de la agricultura de subsistencia
el gobierno ha construido plantas de
generación de energía eléctrica y
carreteras que han conseguido mejorar la
productividad del campo hoy en día los
agricultores ruandeses están
empezando a exportar a sus países
vecinos todo esto explica que 23 años
después del genocidio ruanda esté
creciendo a una media del 8% año tras
año
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea esto es un
ritmo incluso superior que el de muchas
economías emergentes como china o
vietnam en las mismas calles donde en
1994 los vecinos se mataban a machetazos
ahora surgen empresas como la ruanda
motorcycles company que es una fábrica
de motos que se ha creado este mismo año
2017 con capital estadounidense mientras
en el resto de los países de la región
se necesitan semanas o incluso meses
para crear una empresa en ruanda solo
hacen falta dos días para hacer todos
los papeles y como os podéis imaginar
eso ha traído a toda clase de inversores
internacionales sobre todo de china y
eeuu pero os preguntaréis cómo han
llegado hasta aquí cuál es el secreto de
paul kagamé pues mis queridos amigos de
visual política la respuesta tiene sus
luces pero también sus sombras
[Música]
tolerancia a punta de pistola todo el
mundo lo reconoce
ruanda es un país que funciona las
calles son seguras y la tolerancia entre
hutus y tutsis está impuesta por ley la
propia constitución ruandesa prohíbe
terminantemente utilizar estos términos
para referirse una persona todos son
ruandeses sin importar la tribu de donde
vengan y ni las instituciones ni los
medios de comunicación pueden lanzar
ningún mensaje que pueda incitar ni
siquiera ligeramente a abrir las heridas
del pasado
es más ni siquiera pueden criticar al
gobierno y tanto la policía como el
ejército están presentes en todo el país
para garantizar que así sea sí es cierto
porque hágame es un presidente cercano
al pueblo conocido por tener su canal de
youtube un twitter y un facebook que
utiliza casi a diario
nadie más tiene la libertad para
expresar sus ideas libremente y lo mismo
ocurre con el resto de partidos
políticos hablamos de un presidente que
lleva ya 17 años en el poder y que gana
elecciones con resultados que superan el
95 por ciento como os podéis imaginar
esto tiene poco de democrático
ninguno de sus opositores
frank habineza del único partido de
oposición ha intentado presentarse a las
elecciones del año 2010 pero su partido
no pudo registrarse para las votaciones
en otras palabras el modelo ruandés se
fundamenta en tres pilares facilidad
para invertir dinero desde el extranjero
y hacer negocios construcción de
infraestructuras y por encima de todo un
gobierno autoritario que garantiza la
seguridad y la tolerancia a base de
reprimir el resto de derechos
[Música]
en muchos casos estas leyes que en
principio se habían preparado para
prevenir potenciales mensajes que
incitan al odio racial se están
utilizando hoy en día para atacar a
todos los enemigos políticos de paul
kagamé
sitios voy a dejar con la pregunta final
os parece legítima esta falta de
democracia y de libertades si a cambio
un país puede salir de la miseria más
absoluta o tal vez pensáis que ruanda
debería abrirse a un modelo democrático
como el que tenemos en europa o en buena
parte de latinoamérica podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
si queréis conocer a fondo otro país
africano en este vídeo os cuento la
historia de angola el país más caro del
mundo y como siempre recordad que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones que se ha mostrado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]